[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
preparing for this already
[Music]
I didn't hit you with a cane there's
going to be a great gravis so exciting
so it's a wonderful wonderful raise the
bar up to arthritis I'm just I'm just a
little piece on the end they're better
nevertheless
yes because now
[Music]
[Applause]
ready
[Applause]
[Music]
and then and then Harry would come back
in and we'll do the whole scene - Mary
sits up here and it will stop very good
hey cameraman from the top these four
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they start to start to levitate and then
they start to swirl all around when they
start dancing
so does it start like that it starts
like this
thank you
welcome to our shell of shows it is my
great honor to introduce this evening's
renowned guest the one the only Mary
Poppins
[Applause]
[Music]
sacrum a B and C Mo's thank you whatever
you talking about where did you get that
kite I found in the pock Vince
close your mouth please Michael we are
still not a codfish gene banks still
rather inclined to giggle I see
[Music]
so he's hanging there and that's when
you see I can't watch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because of this big Joel can't jump over
there until you get there
[Music]
[Music]
I received a call from Rob Marshall and
he left a very ceremonious what charged
voicemail on my phone saying I had to
call him I was like oh god what is it
and he pitched me the idea of doing the
sequel to Mary Poppins and they wanted
to do it with me so I was blown away by
the whole idea of it
MARY POPPINS was what opened my mind up
in the world up to movies and magic and
music so doing a sequel to Mary Poppins
do you know the first thing you think is
gulp but then you realize that there
were eight books altogether there was a
real sense that there's so much more
story to be told it's really exciting I
mean the chance to explore that world
even more in this new original story
with incredible enchanting original
music still what it was pretty clear
there was no one else that could play
this role as brilliantly as Emily Blunt
well brings you here after all this time
the same thing that brought me the first
time I've come to look after the banks
children oh yes you too
it's so wonderful the soul of the movie
it's about the power of the imagination
it was a real sense that were part of
something very special
we all cared so deeply about the project
because this is a film with great hope
and spectacle and it's moving so I think
it's a very important film to be making
right now
are we ready ready